one of the primary features and it
really is a feature for them it's not a
bug of reactionary right-wing
culture-based politics
is to create enemies
and then to argue that you are going to
fight against them and that they are
dangerous and that they are a threat to
your way of life and that they are a
threat to america and all of these
different things and one such enemy for
the modern reactionary republican
is
the vague idea of communism communists
among our ranks they might be in the
house of representatives they might be
in the senate they might be in your
schools teaching your kids things
and
i have just a delightful clip for you
here
ron desantis who is the governor of uh
florida he's in the middle of a
re-election campaign he's up for for
re-election in november of 2022.
he did an event called
honoring victims of communism now i'm
the first to tell you
that i am not a communist i am against
any kind of authoritarianism
uh many
uh
uh
and and when you say communist regime
some will say they weren't really
communist
many so-called or believed communist
regimes in history have been
authoritarian and i'm against
authoritarianism no matter what it is
wrapped in
and i also recognize that this is a
completely bogus event at which ron
desantis is um a virtue signal signaling
for lack of a better term and this is
just my favorite thing he talks about
the argentinian marxist revolutionary
leader che guevara
and he pronounces his name cheikh
quevara
he's furious with cheik
but he doesn't even know his name it's
this is the epitome of everything that
is wrong with this right wing
reactionary movement let's take a look
at it you can see at a college campus
students flying the hammer and sickle
from the old soviet union flag you will
see students that will have t-shirts
with chai kevara
che kevara on the t-shirts you will see
students that will idolize people
like mao zedong
dung that to me speaks of a tremendous
ignorance
about what those individuals represented
in the now
i am not fans of the i'm not a fan of
the people that desantis is mentioning
here
but guys i mean an event honoring the
victims of communism this is just
another one of these sort of red scare
anti-communist type rants now
the the the legacy
uh of el che as we knew him in argentina
it's uh it's it's not a legacy that is
thrilling to me right i mean it's a it
was a revolutionary
uh guerrilla leader
wanted to overturn capitalism
everywhere by almost whatever means
might work
uh the whole
history of it is that guevara met the
castro brothers
and joined their movement uh in cuba to
overthrow batista
and ushered in the decades and decades
and decades of authoritarian rule by the
castros and um ultimately ended up
playing
uh i'm trying to to do this sort of like
as fairly as possible
controversial roles in various attempted
revolutions all over the world including
uh unsuccessfully in congo kinshasa
later in bolivia ultimately guevara was
captured
by
cia-assisted bolivian forces and
executed
and uh
guevara is not a hero to me
but the virtue signaling and reactionary
fear-mongering
uh by desantis of you know high
schoolers and college kids who like to
wear the t-shirt uh this is not a major
political issue okay florida has some
serious problems uh housing
affordability crisis in florida
median household income in florida is
34th in the country florida ranked 33rd
in opportunity
infrastructure in florida
extraordinarily problematic public
education in florida really leaves
something to be desired if you rank
states
by their equivalent hdi what's called
the human development index florida
comes in
33rd so it's not good there's all sorts
of problems in florida and desantis is
talking about cheich kavara
at a memorial honoring the victims of
communism it's just absurd and um
i i might i can only imagine that if
desantis does end up running for
president uh challenging
maybe it's going to be challenging trump
we don't know what it's going to look
like in 2024
it's going to be more of the same
reactionary fear-mongering that you can
be absolutely sure of
one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single-use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper are 100 plastic free made
without any virgin tree fibers meaning
no new trees are cut down but real paper
is super soft and durable you don't have
to sacrifice quality to help the planet
these are great products from a
usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home all orders ship in 100
recyclable
plastic free packaging everybody needs
paper towels and toilet paper buy ones
that you will feel good about real paper
is available in 12 pack boxes at
targettarget.com and the target app so
let's stop flushing our forests and give
reels tree free paper a try